sur pas compris monique le but du jeu
c'est de faire bosser les autres ces
propos c'est soi même ton avis pourquoi
je me suis fait chier on a trouvé une
idée géniale
ce qui compte maintenant c'est
l'individu doit qu'ils se prennent en
main papa et maman vous avez jamais clos
capitalisant jamais au karl marx qui va
t'aider à avoir un jacuzzi ou une
pergola
car j'en sais aussi c'est c'est la
liberté moi si j'en aurai bas
chardonnerets et j'en donnerai aux
autres at war à tout le monde évidemment
voilà oui c'est bien ça le problème ray
ça c'est bien pour cela que nous les
mineurs on regarde tout le gâteau les
losers ils passeraient leur temps à
surfer à la miette
mais la fin ils auraient pu le gâteau
comme vous êtes 7 milliards
c'est moi je veux bien patienter micouin
je suis chez l'entreprise
ça fait dix minutes que j'attends là je
termine la whey si c'est pour fabriquer
une bombe atomique artisanale c'est
peut-être attendait mieux c'est en train
de faire mon cv la chômeurs en plus dis
moi tu n'aurais pas à 1.15 d'un
businessman genre biopic bill gates mi
temps de réfléchir dans celle qu'ont les
autres espèces j'ai dû perdre de temps
la lecture est très fort
[Musique]
ça